a lot of you guys may be well aware that
ecology black ops just came out tuesday
and i got the prestige version which
came to this amazing rc-xd surveillance
visual so i am going to serve a
promenade now what's awesome about this
is all day again right there so whatever
that little guys to use I see right
there you see that you see that BRE yeah
Katie can you see my face on that screen
anybody play Call of Duty
I want a puppet we're gonna shut me down
apparently they're a big fan of
I gotta get a lay of land I need to know
what's going on up here
professor is hot on our trail
but I'm even hotter on the trails in
case I got something they don't in rc-xd
surveillance cameras premises to secure